le premier ministre madame et messieurs
les ministres chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à madame la ministre
de la transition écologique et solidaire
et merci par ailleurs mme collègue laure
darcos de me céder sa place sur un sujet
sensible qui m'impressionne beaucoup
la défense du rail des usagers et des
cheminots si elles étaient rappelés
l'accident du ter compétences régionales
qui dans les ardennes la semaine
dernière il y a une semaine reliant
charleville mézières à reims alors tiens
convoi exceptionnel qui est resté coincé
sur un passage à niveau
onze blessés malgré son état de choc et
ses blessures le conducteur et aider les
passagers blessés plusieurs ont été
hospitalisés grâce à son s'offre le
conducteur seul a évité de justesse un
sur accident qui aurait pu s'avérer
dramatiques pour les 80 passagers
il a en effet plongé les voix sur plus
d'un kilomètre pour avertir le train
suivant drame évité grâce à sa
conscience professionnelle à ce
conducteur attaché à son métier qui a
d'ailleurs tenu à rester discret cet
accident met en lumière malheureusement
des dysfonctionnements des difficultés
récurrentes d'organisation de la sncf
retards réguliers mécontentement des
usagers mais aussi des agents qui va
croissant par ailleurs la prise en
otages des passagers n'est pas forcément
la meilleure solution
la sncf fonctionne mal les raisons sont
multiples et la réforme
malheureusement ni rien changé madame la
ministre l'administration de votre
collègue madame pays communistes du
travail recommande à la sncf de
suspendre le dispositif agents seule la
disparition des contrôleurs et des
moyens humains n'est pas la bonne
solution nous aimerions connaître vos
positions en am la ministre quels moyens
sont mis en place pour lutter contre la
fraude dans les trains dépourvus de
contrôleurs c'est cet accident rappelle
également la dangerosité des passages à
niveau où en sommes-nous madame la
ministre dans l'exécution programme
national de sécurisation des passages à
niveau qui avait fait l'objet d'une
opération de communication de votre part
il ya quelques mois
merci d'écouter d'entendre les élus de
proximité les usagers les chemins